hey there folks Chris waters here to
host you on our continuing look at steam
early access games survival is the theme
today and it's an appropriate one given
how early access purchases can often
provide a sustaining boost to
development teams to help them finish
their games plus there's just like a ton
of survival games on early access so
today we're going to see how different
three games on the same subject can be
or how not different as the case may be
in the world of rust you must contend
with cold hunger thirst and unhinged
maniacs whose only wish in the world is
to smash your head in with a big old
rock for this report we go to GameSpot's
resident unhinged maniac himself Sean
McGuinness did no good no good they feel
good at nobu otoko rust is an open world
survival game where you pretty much
start out as a caveman see your only
weapon at the beginning of this game is
a big clumsy rock but as you run around
chipping away at trees and boulders will
soon harvest enough resources to craft
all kinds of stuff whether it's a
hatchet a bow and arrow or even a
campfire to cook meat but the crafting
doesn't end there see those buildings
actual players created those it's that
focus on crafting tools and building
structures that really sets this game
apart from Daisy but just like Daisy
interactions between players are a big
part of the fun sure you can join a no
pvp server to craft in peace but where's
the fun in that this bear is dead
gentlemen we may feast upon the spoils
what makes rust so entertaining is that
you never know whether another player is
going to give you survival tips or trade
items with you or simply kill you on
sight there's a lot of work left to be
done with rust like the way you collect
chicken breasts from a dead bear but
there's a huge amount of potential here
for twenty dollars you can have a lot of
fun with rust shotgun well he died as he
lived awkwardly with his butt hunched up
in the air
the title of our next game is 7 days to
die is it a challenge meant to be defied
is it a goal meant to be achieved is it
a laughable impossibility that no one
could ever accomplish and it's meant to
make you feel like you're bad at video
games I'll let you decide for yourself
which one it was for me
in seven days to die you must survive
the zombie apocalypse but there's no
helicopter waiting on the roof to whisk
you away to safety no safe refuge to
flee to you're in it for the long haul
so after you've scavenged some weapons
and food from the houses cars and piles
of garbage it's time to get crafty this
is a minecraftian world in which you
punch dirt to get sand punch trees to
get wood and then with a little luck in
ingenuity build yourself a towering
Palace to stand the test of time or just
like plug up a doorway and hope for the
best you can go it alone and hope to
survive the waves of nasties that come
after you but combat is not where this
game shines seven days really works
better as a cooperative game where you
can learn from the more experienced
players pool your efforts and resources
and take better advantage of the pretty
neat crafting system on the early access
spectrum seven days is definitely closer
to the alpha stage so unless you're a
voxel holic looking for your next fix it
might behoove you to wait a little while
before digging into this zombiecraft
apocalypse
remember that time that Daisy was a game
that you could play but it was actually
a mod so they decided to make a full
game and call that Daisy but then that
was in beta for the foreseeable future
it's all right keeping track of these
things can be hard sometimes that's why
we've got Thai route with an update on
the freshest Daisy of the bunch once an
insanely popular ARMA 2 mod dayz is now
a full-fledged standalone alpha title
and the dev team has a very clear
warning for you if you do not know what
an alpha is or do not want to support
the dead process of dayz don't buy this
game but if you're a fan of insta death
or games like rust and terraria and you
want to participate in a grand social
experiment that very well could
accurately portray a real-life zombie
apocalypse then Daisy is for you and for
those who played the original mod it may
be worth checking out again since dayz
standalone has a number of big
improvements especially when it comes to
your inventory it will start off as a
random survivor on the island of generis
with nothing more than a flashlight and
the clothes on your back it's up to you
to stay conscious long enough to find
food water shelter supplies and weapons
all things necessary to stay alive in
busy because once you're dead you're
dead it's survival of the fittest and
Daisy and when you run into another
human all bets are off do you surrender
and hope for mercy do you call for a
truce do you attempt to join forces well
in case you're still on the fence just
know it's possible for other players to
detain and handcuff you while their
squad mates drain you of your blood just
before the shoot you in the face and
steal your [ __ ] to me that is [ __ ]
awesome
another three games down another entry
in gamespot's steam early access special
complete those were three of the most
directly comparable games we've featured
so far so I fully expect all of you to
get down the comments below and chime in
on which perilous program you'd prefer
to play and yes you get bonus points for
alliteration I'll see you tomorrow for
the final episode